biggest stock rises in 2020 inspired by
whatever the hell this gamestop thing is
and i have decided to carve out time of
my otherwise
very busy day of copying pasting and
snarky commenting
to understand exactly what the hell is
going on with gamestop because
it's all everybody's talking about i
don't know what the hell it is i know
and you're like the last guy to get a cb
radio so uh
okay trivia question for you before we
do this gamestop draft
tom brady is already the buccaneers
all-time leader in playoff touchdown
passes with
seven he will likely pass brad johnson
for the most franchise playoff passing
yards
in the super bowl he trails only by 12
yards i would say he'll
he should do that barring something
entirely unforeseen he'll break that
record
which quarterback holds the buccaneers
record
for the best completion percentage in
the playoffs
you're smirking and i don't i don't know
the answer
okay i don't know the answer okay well i
know it's not i do now with my one
um man it's not a lot of quarterbacks of
course that have done this uh you know
as far as playoffs and the bucks i'm
gonna go with sean king
i'm gonna say he had some crazy game
darn it
it's you is it me you're a big idiot
well
you know i was gonna say it was me but
the way you like had that little smirk
on your face but
i didn't i yeah i didn't know it just
tells you i don't pay attention to that
kind of crap
i threw two interceptions in that game
and i i graded out as one of my better
games in my whole career but uh
not a historian not not a he's not not
for me who the hell cares about chris
sims history
and it's perfect because your dad's got
the highest completion percentage
in super bowl history that's why i
smirked it's the perfect stat
for you it's perfect that's the only
parallel you can draw from
me and my dad's career right there
that's right yeah i get the first pick
uh i'm gonna go james robinson
who else undrafted from one of the
directional illinois i think it's
eastern i'm not sure
goes in to jacksonville is the week one
starter right
and is phenomenal and once again turns
on the head the idea that you need to
use a first round pick on a running back
no you don't no you don't or second or
third or fourth or fifth or sixth or
seventh
you can find a guy if your scouts are
good enough right who isn't even drafted
who can come in and take over the
position
no that that's a good one i wrote that
name down to
certainly i mean came out of nowhere to
where
and then the first week we were like
whoa this guy looks pretty good and we
continue to say that throughout the year
so that was amazing
all right nobody stock rose more than
giddy up giddy up kitty up josh allen
giddy up giddy up it's my boy blue i
mean
nobody i mean look at the transformation
this year
it went from everybody hating on him and
he still can't
completion percentage and i'm not sure
and he's raw
to the end of the year everybody had
their lips puckered up and were kissing
his butt and everything had changed
around
and they were going whoa he is one of
the best quarterbacks in football
that that to me was the biggest stock
riser of the year
where he was questioned a lot to where
we got here in the last month
where it was over and you started
watching shows like you and me to where
nobody can deny it anymore there was
nothing you could say
he's definitely one of the best
quarterbacks in football so i'm gonna go
with josh allen there
yeah i think you're selling short the
the the starting point
for sure there were some people who were
still sure who were still
but but i you know he he did take a jump
he did not as big of a jump as justin
herbert because we didn't know anything
about justin herbert that's my next pick
yeah good we didn't know what he was
going to be we didn't know what he was
going to do
and he's already vaulted into your top
five right he's is he in your top five
your top ten ten yeah top ten
yeah still pretty good yeah for a guy
that we didn't know anything about and
he got picked after tua
and after joe burrow and this guy was
the best of all of them he'll be the
well i mean joe burrow would have been
the best if he hadn't been injured but
herbert's going to be the
nfl's offensive rookie of the year yeah
right it's close i mean he
hey you you joe burrow justin herbert it
doesn't matter you give me either one
i'm not sure i wouldn't take justin
herbert after the year i saw
you know we talked about it last year
and just
herbert in the evaluation of the draft
last year i know i said it many times
his
ceiling was greater than burroughs and
we saw that this year and you're right
stock went through the roof oh i don't
know if he can live outside the bubble
of oregon
and i don't know if he has the
personality to be a quarterback
zoom zoom laser beams everywhere how
about that personality
um okay i think
i'm going to go with dk metcalf as my
next one
went into the year like i understand
that people
knew he was a freak and good and had
that great wild card game last year
against the philadelphia eagles to end
that 2019 season where carson wentz got
hurt and all that
but i feel like this year with all the
highlight plays the way he started out
the year
the running down um of of uh
the safety in in arizona who on buddha
baker
and that play and the whole you know the
memes and the social media attention to
all of that
i feel like he went to hey this guy's a
freak
and looks really good too whoa is he
maybe the best receiver in football i
think he made that type of jump this
year and i'll i'll say i would have
certainly
wish i would have been on buying stock
for for dk metcalf
right but i think the time to sell would
have been mid-november because
it went down a little bit yeah once they
caught up to the offense down a little
bit and i
i've gravitated toward rookies you've
gotten
i know guys so far i'm gonna go with a
guy who's deeper into his career that
made a change via trade got a contract
and
and became a force of nature whereas he
wasn't
even though he was really good with the
49ers we didn't think of deforest
buckner as a force of nature
until he went to india yeah and kind of
took over that defense
and and when he's not in the game they
got no chance i mean that was kind of
the attitude
they got to have deforest buckner if
they want to have a chance in this game
he comes back and
everything's different so to me i think
it was because when they make the trade
you're like
man that's a lot to give up and they're
giving him this huge contract on the way
through the door okay
let's see and he ends up you know really
emerging as one of the top interior
defensive lineman in football maybe
second only to aaron donald that's right
yeah i mean definitely one of the top
defensive players in the league you're
right it's a great pick
so you know there's nothing wrong with
yeah he was on the radar
we knew he was good this year kind of
confirmed him being great and we went
whoa
no we saw him what in like two games
where he didn't play they were not the
same defense so
uh i'm with you i got no problem with
that i think that i'm gonna go
man i got so there's a lot of good ones
out there i'm gonna just throw out i
mean
hassan reddick is one i think about i
mean talk about improving your stock
guy had more sacks in one game than he
did in his whole career basically at one
point this year
i'm gonna go to your team though justin
jefferson
you know another one of my favorites in
the draft
but man did he show what he was worth
this year
and everything he can do i mean he's
still it's still going upwards
he can do it all there's nothing justin
jefferson can't do on the football field
phenomenal rookie receiver and looks
like he's gonna be around for a long
time
i agree with you he was on my list as
well and just jamming a couple other
names here i had jk dobbins of the race
good one was great as a rookie and
antoine winfield jr
sure buccaneers who really flashed in
that playoff game but he got better and
better all year long who else did you
have that didn't make it
jonathan taylor is another rookie i
threw on there i mean you're top three
in rushing in the nfl
you know that that was big time stock
job i think like guys like you know
aj brown where we went like whoa this
guy was a good rookie to now oh
is he a top five receiver in football i
think he's there
and even a terry mclaurin with the the
washington football team
yeah they weren't sexy offensively but i
think he's put himself in that you know
top receiver conversation too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports